hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring in this video what we're going
to talk about is a related rate problem
something you come across in your
calculus class and how to approach it
and how to solve it specifically this
one's going to be about a cone and let's
get right into the problem and see how
we solve it so a conical tank with a
vertex down is 6 feet across okay at the
top and 4 feet deep water is flowing
into the tank at 10 feet cubed per
minute find the rate of change of the
depth of the water when the water is 3
feet deep ok so when you do these
related rate problems they might seem
overwhelming at first if you know
there's more than a couple steps it's
you know a little bit more complicated
so what you want to do is you want to
draw a diagram ok so the first thing I
would do is let's just draw a diagram so
here's the cone okay and it's facing
down says the vertex is down like this
it's 6 feet across
ok so let's just draw that in there 6
feet across ok and it tells us that it's
4 feet deep ok so there's 4 right there
ok so that step number one is to draw a
diagram step number 2 is to find out
what we know and also to identify what
we're trying to find so what we know is
that the change in the volume okay
because water is you know going into
this tank the change in the volume DV DT
that rate okay is 10 feet cubed per
minute but what we want to find is we
want to find the change in the depth or
in this case I'll just call it the
height so say for example the water is
like filling up like this hold the
height we want to know what dhdt is when
the height is at a level of 3 feet deep
ok so that's step number 2 now step
number 3 is we want to find an equation
that relates you know the things that we
know with the things that we don't know
and in this particular problem ok
sometimes with these problems once you
see the little technique or trick it
makes it a lot easier and I'm going to
show you that right here and basically
what it is is you see this triangle
that's formed right here okay you
actually have two triangles one that's
like this 4 and 3 3 because it's half
the diameter okay so the radius is 3 and
you have the smaller triangle that's
formed these are
similar triangles okay so this is each
and this cell just call R for the radius
okay I have the smaller circle here so
these triangles are similar because you
know this angle is the same this angles
the same these are both right angles so
by angle-angle similarity from geometry
the two triangles are similar which
means that we can form a proportion with
the two triangles okay so next thing
we're gonna do is we write an equation
so our equation looks like this volume
okay equals one-third area of the base
okay which is a circle PI R squared
times the height so that's the form the
for volume of a cone now you can see
that we have two variables R NH here
okay in addition to the volume so let's
write an equation that relates our NH
using these two similar triangles so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
three is two R as four is 2h okay and
then what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to cross multiply so we get three
H equals four R and then I'm going to
divide both sides by four okay so that
means that R equals R equals three H
divided by four okay what we're going to
do is we're going to put that in place
of our here this way we get everything
in terms of V and H's okay so V equals
1/3 pi the radius is three H over four
okay squared times H and if we simplify
that down we get 1/3 PI 9 H squared over
four actually I'm starting over 16
because we're squaring times H and then
let's see if we simplify it down a
little bit further we get let's see 9
divided by 3 is going to give me 3 pi H
cubed over 16 equals the volume okay now
we're ready to take the derivative we're
going to do the implicit differentiation
we're going to take the derivative the
respect to time or T and so that's going
to be DV DT equals 3 PI over 16 okay
this is just a constant this whole thing
pi is just a constant as well take the
derivative H cubed which is going to be
3 H squared and we have to do the chain
rule dhdt
so I'm just bringing down the 3
okay subtracting one from the exponent
that's just the power rule when you take
the derivative and then not take the
chain rule to take the derivative the
inside that's dhdt I'm going to simplify
this down a little bit further so this
gives you 9 PI over 16 H squared D H DT
equals DV DT okay so let's substitute in
what we know solve for what we don't
know when we've got it so DV DT they
tell us is 10 and they want to know what
the change in the height is okay when
the height of the water in this conical
tank is 3 so that means that H is going
to be 3 squared which is 9 times dhdt
now at this point we're pretty much done
the only thing left to do is basically
you know multiply by the reciprocal to
get the dhdt by itself so we'll just do
that math real quickly this is 81 PI
over 16 so I'm going to multiply by 16
over 81 pi which gives you 160 over 81
pi equals dhdt
so many students get a little bit
confused about the units but this is the
change in height we've been calculating
everything in feet and you can see that
the volume it wasn't going in there at
the rate of 10 feet cubed per minute
okay so this the unit's here are going
to be feet per minute okay so what this
means is you can see it's positive so
that means that this is filling up so
the height is increasing okay it's
positive its increasing at the rate of
160 divided by 81 pi that's an exact
answer feet per minute so I hope you
enjoyed this video I hope to help you
understand how to work with the related
rates a little bit better you can check
out my other video about the ladder
problem you know where it's sliding down
the wall that's also a good problem that
comes up a lot and it'll help you to
understand how to work through the
different steps subscribe to the channel
check out some of my past videos and I
look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon